good evening and welcome to a special
edition of Tucker Carlson tonight when
was the last time you heard a democratic
politician propose a solution to a
problem no matter what the problem is
that didn't make the Democratic party
more powerful ponder that for a moment
let's say for example that you really
believe global warming was an
existential threat to humanity and that
Rising carbon dioxide levels were
causing global warming what would you do
to fix it
well you might think back to 10th grade
biology class CO2 CO2 hmm don't trees
consume huge amounts of CO2 for
photosynthesis quick Google check why
yes they do
so how about we plant a whole lot more
trees all across the country and across
the world
that seems like a natural solution with
lots of upsides trees are beautiful it
might help fight global warming oh but
no there's a problem with that idea
planting more trees might help solve
climate change but it definitely will
not enrich your donors trees are cheap
it's hard to make money from trees and
worse than that trees are impossible to
regulate once you plant trees they grow
by themselves they do not need Federal
help trees definitely will not make you
more powerful so instead here's an idea
let's invest trillions of dollars of
other people's money in batteries and
wind farms and electric school buses
that way Democratic politicians get
fingertip control over the entire U.S
economy and all of their friends get
rich
sounds perfect let's go with that idea
that's how Democratic politicians think
every one of them
so it probably should not surprise you
that Elizabeth Warren has a brand new
plan for Rising gas prices and naturally
it goes without saying that plan would
give Elizabeth Warren a lot more control
over you and over the United States well
hold on a minute you may be wondering
why should Elizabeth Warren have control
over anything Elizabeth Warren isn't
very bright she's never created anything
in fact she's a proven liar this is a
person who exploited the suffering of
American Indians to get a job promotion
the Trail of Tears means I need tenure
okay so in every possible way Elizabeth
Warren is mediocre
yet and here's the catch she's also a
U.S senator and that means she has power
Warren's latest plan to make herself
more powerful is called the price
gouging prevention Act of 2022. this
bill would allow Elizabeth Warren to
decide what things cost in the United
States
so let's say you're paying six bucks a
gallon for gas and you may be the
obvious solution to that in fact the
only solution to that is to make more
gasoline because if there is more of
something it will cost less
that's not just basic economics though
it is it's also a law of nature it never
changes but Elizabeth Warren wants the
opposite she does not want more gas in
fact she's worked hard to prevent the
United States from producing more
gasoline and that's the main reason it's
so expensive
what Elizabeth Warren wants instead is
control over gasoline and over
everything else and this bill will give
it to her see how this works
and this is why the bid Administration
has shut down oil and gas leases in the
middle of an energy crisis and not just
that they're crushing refineries
according to one analysis by hot air
quote seven American refineries which
formerly processed 806 thousand barrels
of oil per day have gone offline some
simply shut down while others were being
converted to biofuels like ethanol to
meet the demands of the environmental
Lobby
these losses have left the United States
with 124 operating oil refineries that
is 10 percent fewer refineries for
gasoline Diesel and jet fuel than we had
in 2016 even as demand has continued to
increase
end quote
did you see how this is going no more
oil or gas for you and that's why you
can't afford to fill your tank instead
the bite Administration is demanding
that states build wind turbines that
sound good but unfortunately don't
actually work last year we went to Texas
to see this firsthand here's a clip from
our documentary on the tragic buffoonery
of wind power
with no chance of being approved near
Malibu or Greenwich or in the mountains
of Aspen the development invariably
happens in poorer parts of the country
the number one place for wind farms is
Texas but the question is what happens
when the turbine stops spinning we're in
the middle of nowhere in Texas we're
trying to find a place just to sleep
tonight everything is sold out there's
nothing available it's now expected to
be the largest Insurance claim event in
Texas history this winter storm totally
overwhelmed the power system in Texas I
can tell you this morning nearly 4.2
million Texans still have no electricity
Texas has the most wind power capacity
in the United States but the Texas
turbines which are not winterized iced
up during a cold weather event in
February of 2021 electricity output
collapsed Texas Regulators ordered
rolling blackouts Monday as an Arctic
blast's Frozen wind turbines there's no
water in the hotel the Texas grid like
the California grid is becoming
increasingly unreal reliable and
difficult to maintain difficult to keep
that power in a steady basis this 20
year old turbine is leaking oil
doesn't look too green to me
so the point of an energy grid is to
produce and transmit energy it has only
one purpose and that purpose is being
sabotaged on purpose by the by
demonstration and by Wall Street in
favor of green energy in favor of
windmills that don't actually work and
as a result of that we're facing the
prospect of more blackouts this summer
we don't have electricity anymore it's a
first world country but Elizabeth Warren
has a fix for that quote it shall be
unlawful for a person to sell or offer
for sale a good or services at an
unconscionably excessive price during
exceptional Market shock regardless of
the person's position in the supply
chain or distribution Network
so the argument here this Elizabeth
Warren's argument the economy has been
in a period of exceptional Market shock
since the pandemic began therefore
prices set by every industry across the
country would fall under the regulatory
authority of who Elizabeth Warren most
of the price gouging bills are limited
to specific areas during natural
disasters but this one is not it's
economy-wide and it's forever
now the question is how exactly does
Elizabeth Warren Define quote
unconscionably excessive prices because
they're not defined in the legislation
so it turns out the definition is up to
can you guess Elizabeth Warren
any business with gross annual revenues
over 100 Grand a year that means pretty
much everybody in the Country Must Now
obey
Elizabeth Warren
that means Elizabeth Warren read the
power to say set the price of say diesel
fuel that's what we use to fuel trucks
that transport virtually everything that
you buy or consume the entire US economy
depends on diesel as CBS reported
recently diesel prices are getting close
to the point where truckers can't work
anymore watch is the astroduction fuel
price is like six dollars and 39 cents a
gallon imagine paying that for a fill-up
of more than 100 gallons a regular fill
up would have been just say six months
ago
about seven hundred dollars
now it's about a thousand it's what
truckers are facing across the country
for diesel and you're paying the price
according to oil analyst Tom clusa if
you're ordering anything that moves by
Freight across the country it comes via
uh fuel surcharges probably not the
worst of the diesel surcharges that'll
come next month I just don't think
there's any Magic Bullet at the moment
it's going to be tough it's going to be
a tough summer
so most projections suggest that this
and by this we mean the price of energy
is going to get worse and that's exactly
of course what Elizabeth Warren is
counting on your suffering she hopes
Americans get so desperate that they go
to her to set the price of diesel along
with everything else that's bought or
sold in the United States economy and
when that happens what happens
interesting question so at this point a
lot of money is floating around the US
economy and that's because of government
spending federal reserve prints money it
goes to the banks then it filters down
to Wall Street and they buy bigger
houses and yet at the same time supplies
of essential goods are very limited so
when you impose price controls in that
kind of environment anyone anyone
bidding wars start and prices go up even
higher as The Economist Alan Cole put it
recently you'll inevitably get a
scalper's paradise government imposed
prices will be low so they'll sell out
fast of course then you get a black
market we don't have to guess because
this has happened in every controlled
economy in history the Bolsheviks
learned this early when they imposed
price controls so what do you do next if
you're the government imposing these
controls if you crack down on scalpers
and that's what Elizabeth Warren's bill
would do
so you get a lot more law enforcement
activity a lot of people going to jail
but you also get with the economist
Gregory Grossman calls the second
economy so people do anything they can
to get the government-approved lower
price the Soviets traded favored verse
and established protection rackets they
call the system blot which translated
from the Polish meant someone who
provides cover
what you get is corruption corruption is
the inevitable result of price controls
even the Soviets learned this after
almost 70 years that's why Gorbachev
abandoned price controls in the 1990s
Nicholas Maduro thougha
pretty rigorous Marxist also abandoned
price controls in Venezuela he did that
three years ago in the 1970s Richard
Nixon also realized can you imagine
price controls don't work but only after
he Froze all prices and wages in the
United States and that eventually led to
a massive spike in demand and
double-digit inflation
so people who don't understand basic
economic principles probably shouldn't
fool around with the economy but they
can never control themselves and that's
why some of the biggest figures in the
Democratic party right now want to
repeat mistakes we have seen countless
times not just Elizabeth Warren it's the
supposedly moderate Bob Casey Sheldon
Whitehouse is not very bright and Bernie
Sanders and Ed Markey and Jeff Markley
and Tammy Duckworth and Dianne Feinstein
they're all on board with this bill and
then the house you've got Jerry Nadler
David cisolini of Rhode Island the
former mob lawyer Katie Porter of
California wrote Connor of Silicon
Valley Bobby Rush of Chicago they've all
co-sponsored the legislation
so they're hoping as they do that you
won't open Wikipedia to find out what
happened when every other country in
history tried this
they definitely don't want you looking
at the history of the Soviet Union and
that's why that history is no longer
taught in schools
instead they want you to watch reports
like this and in fear give them total
control over your economy
the shifting and shrinking School lunch
menu supply chain disruptions and the
spiraling cost of key ingredients is for
school districts to pull back or make
substitutions at some schools no more
hamburgers or chicken patty sandwiches
due to problems and the price of buying
buns and ketchup a new survey of school
districts Nationwide reveals 97 percent
of meal programs reported challenges
with higher costs while 98 acknowledge
problems getting some menu items the
supplies and the ingredients costs are
poised to rise again for U.S schools
July 1st when an emergency measure
enacted at the start of the pandemic
expires
so we're not Shilling for big business
here we don't work for Joe Biden we
don't have to in fact we're often
nightly critical of big business but
let's be honest for a second does any
serious person actually believe that
hamburger and chicken patty
manufacturers are holding back supplies
of their products because they're greedy
that's not what's happening we wish it
were what's happening because you could
probably fix that
but that's what they're telling you is
happening
and they're telling you that so you'll
believe it they want you to believe that
the baby formula shortage isn't about
Supply it's about pricing
unfortunately that's just not true
here's NBC with the latest figures on
the shortage
the FDA telling NBC News it is concerned
not having certain formulas available on
shelves could pose life-threatening
risks for infants mom Sydney Galvin says
she's been grappling with the shortage
for two months after their formula was
recalled how are you dealing
day by day to be honest unable to find
her formula on shelves she had no choice
but to suddenly switch Brands Texas has
been hit particularly hard the formula
out of stock rate here is now 50 percent
oh so the key line was the last line the
out of stock rate is now 50 so they just
don't have the product because companies
generally if they have the product or
eager to sell the product because
they're in the business of selling
products make money
but unfortunately if you have no
grounding in economics at all not even
theoretical but practical like if your
whole life is consisted of lying to
large crowds to get elected to print
more money to pay yourself give yourself
the most generous retirement in the
United States you probably don't know
how anything works
and that would describe most leaders in
the Democratic party so their solution
not surprisingly is the Soviet solution
it will make the prod problem worse but
it will make them more powerful oh do
you not like that
oh we're sorry we'd love to hear your
complaints but we're not available at
the moment we've flown private to a
global warming conference
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight